in the film you talk about dreams and I
want to know have you had any weird
dreams lately or a reoccurring Dream
well my recurring nightmare is what used
to be that I was really good friends
with the queen and we used to just
listen to records together but always I
ended up for some reason on the L uh in
in the middle of a big room with the
queen you know and there was no screen
or or door or anything like that really
see this is what I want to hear yeah
what does it mean I don't know but we
have a conscious a subconscious and an
unconscience and it is a layered cake so
that's somewhere in there yes what about
you Tim I don't know I had a strange
alien dream the other night okay that's
rare for me it was a creepy alien dream
okay he's forgetting it's hard it's hard
to remember the details sometimes you
know what I mean well I'll jot them I'll
jot them in my notes sometimes I heard
actually that one of the best pieces of
uh advice you ever got was to journal
yeah is that true yes I try to journal
as much as possible do you still yeah
he's the one that told me to journal um
what is journaling well I I Journal too
and I keep a gratitude Journal yes I
always have it with me and I write it um
with me and my daughters would you
possibly something anything anything
anything that you're grateful for it
could be a taco or it could be a person
or it could be a thing
hu
huma huma looma do you do you have a
gratitude jle don't be
absurd things I hate does that count
absolutely things that enrage me yes
that's what I want what enrages you
right now ah everything everything
everything I I can't work anything I
don't like people wearing iPods I don't
like iPods write something very is that
what they called would you write
something those things in their ears ear
pods they piss me off to to no end um
okay oh okay one of my favorite parts of
the film which I love so much the big
night out candy now Hubert if you were
to eat a big Night Out Chocolate where
are you going who are you calling where
are you waking
up I've had so many big nights out I had
a really bad friend where I did nothing
else but nights out for about six years
classic have you had a big night out
chocolate in real life yes no come on no
never had a big Night Out Chocolate no
just um tonight's the night I think
tonight's the night you know we went to
Japan um to promote this and Hugh said
it was his first time there without
having a big night out yeah speaking of
you aree a purple latex suit um do you
have to powder for something like that
no so the inside was lined it was it was
lined I wondered if they gave you a
special lining that's otherwise it would
have had to you know peel it off right
what was the inspiration for that suit
yeah well it feels like there few movies
like Willy Wonka where you can have fun
you know expressing yourself through
clothing and uh but you always do like
you went backless on the red carpet I'm
like why are more men not going back
list why is it only women uhhuh you
changed that singlehandedly I don't know
about change that but uh when are you
going to do that Hugh Paris on Friday
Paris there you go back list in Paris
yeah but I'm with a Twist CU I'm doing
backlist on my
trousers that's a crazy visual Keegan
does that what what are you going to BU
out then maybe I'll wear maybe you know
what I haven't I haven't I haven't
sported a
cape get some capes going I me start
working some capes into into situations
you know what I mean that's good
a sto bring back the cape bring back the
cape you know yes
[Music]
exactly